[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
rachel cruz we're here for you this hour
triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
toll free number to jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five a lot
of new people rachel joining the show
all the time and i like to remind folks
that some of these calls are very
sensitive in nature one of the things
you may not be aware of we will change
your name kelly is standing by she'll
change your name change your location
because we want to protect the
sensitivity of some of these calls
because we want to meet you right where
you are in your life because we want you
to understand how
your relationships and your professional
life and your money life are all
intertwined and rachel you could be
winning in one of those three areas but
losing in two or whatever formula you
want to look at and it's going to drag
the other one down no matter where
you're winning what you just said money
money relationships and your workloads
okay give me list out yours right now
yeah the bet like the best what's
killing it a work life's killing it okay
so professional number one professional
number one personal is tough because i'm
parenting teens i know so it's like a
role murder is that too
uh oh it's definitely three okay so
money is your number two yeah yeah
would be yeah i'm gonna say
[Applause]
you're in the throes of it
financials three for me right now
you're not
i'm not losing no but i'm not i'm not
killing it like i have been in years
past i pull back a little bit so i'm
home a little bit more so i'd say relate
i'd say uh work number two relation
number one there we go that's good i
went backwards but yeah and again and
again i want to be careful
you know the co first of all the coleman
kids aren't watching so there's no
chance of defending
they're great kids but like i was
telling some people other day i was
telling another dad who's successful in
another area yes and we were just
talking and i was like sometimes i i'll
have this high
i come home and and work has been great
doing something i'm good at something i
love getting feedback from people that
we're helping them transform their lives
you feel pretty good about yourself yeah
then you walk in the door and you feel
like the village idiot inside of the
room
he was like listen man i'm the same way
it's a teenage thing
man i feel like when they're three
same deal
you could have a great day you could do
good morning america you could do all
these things you come home and all they
care about is like [ __ ] took my
toy or yeah who knows and it's hot and
it's just hard it's hard it's hard i
know so we're going to meet you there we
understand we get it y'all let's get it
go elisha joins us in billings montana
elisha how can we help
oh it's elisa oh elisha i'm so sorry i
didn't know if it was a hard eye or soft
eye so there we go elisha
how can we um
i just started
baby
i decided the baby steps um
and
uh
it took me like three months to build up
my emergency fund and i just started
paying off uh the debt that i have
this this last month and uh i
please i actually uh this is horrible
i'm tailing this in front of a whole
bunch of people anyway i accidentally
ran over my dog
no but i already depleted my emergency
fund
yeah
for sure now i'm feeling discouraged
because i'm like you know how long it
took me to build that up i know i know
uh okay so what were the things you did
to help build it up in those three
months what were a couple of things
um uh well
um
i did
i did um
i did some some small some small work
that
that brought in some some money under
the table kind of like
quilting and things like that
and then um
i
kind of cut our grocery fund a little
bit good
okay because the only reason i'm asking
is because in
when we teach the baby steps like that
baby step one we want you to do it in
like 30 days
okay so yeah this next time around i
just i would encourage you kind of pour
the gasoline on right so even if it is
taking a whole other job maybe at maybe
four times a night for just three weeks
four weeks you know what i mean like
whatever it is uh look around and see
okay what what are things we can get rid
of like you said we cut our grocery
budget where we can where can we cut
anything that you can do to get it
faster because here's the deal too is
that
life you're gonna go forward four steps
back to forward three back one i mean
it's just it's this back and forth thing
so the idea of using the emergency fund
it was there which is amazing for when
you needed it that's what it's for but i
totally understand the discouragement of
going backwards
because you think oh i'm just going to
be making forward progress and when you
go backwards i want you to hear it's
normal but i want you to refund it
twice as fast as what you did the first
time just to continue to keep you
motivated yeah i think that's great
advice alicia because here's the deal to
this day anytime i have to use that
emergency fund it irritates me to no end
and i've got it fully funded it drives
me bananas because you know how hard you
worked so i would flip that i i love the
advice that rachel gives but i think
mentally not only do what she's saying
so very intensely get that a thousand
dollar emergency fund back up but also
why you do it i want you to maybe
flip your mindset instead of being
discouraged she told you to get
determined and i think that's great but
i would also realize pat yourself on the
back
instead of being so discouraged that you
had to use it
be encouraged that you worked hard
enough to be able to do it and so when
this horrible thing happened you didn't
go backwards financially i know you
depleted your emergency fund but you
actually didn't go backwards financially
that's why we have the emergency fund
does that make sense
yep it does all right you're doing great
hang in there uh isn't it isn't it
interesting rachel that it's like
life just happens this way when you when
you get serious and you get intentional
to go do something and you get some
momentum it's like we always i don't
know what it is about our humanness
where we just think oh this is going to
be great yeah i'm just going to run up a
hill and i'm never going to sprain my
ankle yeah i'm never going to run into a
thorn bush or wait it's just i'm going
to get there yes well because of life
you're like okay i'm going on an upward
trajectory that i want but the line
doesn't look straight i mean it looks
like
turning and down and up and all that i
mean hopefully over the scope of time
it's it's heading up because we want to
be improving and
learning from mistakes we've made all of
that but it is it is all it's all over
the place it's all over the place yeah
and and how do you handle it when you
when you coach people or you personally
like when someone is in that place and
they're looking at this emergency that
that really comes out and and how do you
determine for somebody that's very early
on in the baby steps
can i move my budget around yeah to make
this a kind of or is it a true emergency
transaction where i'm pulling it out of
the emergency fund does that make sense
so when someone's learning how to budget
right so they've kind of got their
working budget now they've established a
budget yes so now they're on the budget
when something bad happens how do you
determine well this is clearly i'm going
to pull the money from the emergency but
first
maybe i'll move some money from my blow
envelope and try to keep that that's
what i'm asking yeah i mean i would say
for your emergency fund for me it's the
ultimate safety net so if i can't
finagle
things around to have the cash to to do
it
then it's kind of my last resort but
it's there it's that safety net yes okay
so i mean in a perfect world yeah you
would have some stuff over here or
you're planning on making a purchase
this month that didn't happen so you
have that money there you know all of it
but it's um that's my goal is to always
find a way to cash flow it not pull from
the emergency fund but it's there and if
you know like she she did it the right
she did the right way if that's all she
had
and when your budget's that tight that's
why we go to the emergency fund so i
want to make sure you all understand
that but that's a really good word uh
from rachel okay coming up we've got
more of your calls triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're here
for you i know there's breakthrough
coming to somebody today let's go we're
here for you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by rachel cruz we're here
for you this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five rachel it's
finally here
we are back on the road ramsay solutions
events are happening again and i'm very
excited about this the building wealth
live event is coming to las vegas and
orlando this may
and this is a big topic right now a lot
of opinions on how to do it crypto
single stock zero down real estate seems
like everybody wants to get rich and
seems like everybody's giving advice
oh boy stay off of instagram with the
financial advice will you please twitter
yeah so we want you to join me dave
ramsey rachel cruz george campbell and
dr john delony as we unpack these hot
topics and uh john and i
are pumped because we're going to lead a
free bonus session before the main event
we're going to talk through how to
balance your work and relationships so
that you can live a richer more
fulfilled life so get ready las vegas
we're coming to you thursday may 5th
orlando will be in your beautiful town
on thursday may 19th
and uh the rumor is that rachel might
wear her mickey ears on the stage in
orlando you have to show up to see if
this is true or if it's rumor
and we're also excited because we've
just confirmed four more cities stay
tuned more on that next week so we are
ramping up the bus
and uh we're coming to a town near
near you tickets for this building
wealth event start at just 25
or you can get a four pack for only 60
bucks it's a great deal don't wait
ramsay solutions dot com events that's
ramsey solutions dot com slash events
are you excited how pumped are you kids
i'm actually so
we announced it on monday on the show
and i was like i just can't wait i'm
very excited events man yeah we're ready
to live crowd
and you and i have done a lot of events
together i was talking about this one i
was on the show with dave a couple weeks
ago
we do a good job our live events team
does a really great job of creating a
great uh mood in the room it it's not
boring and it's just fun we always have
a great time the energy's there people
are there to get better and to win in
life and that kind of is infectious even
for us on the stage we feel it from the
audience and it's so much fun being with
a live crowd i can't wait to be in a
capacity crowd again do i oh i know oh
yeah so man vegas and orlando two two
fun great cities very funny we are
pumped we're pumped to be with you all
right i'm gonna make sure that they pack
her mickey ears we'll see if we can get
her to wear him on stage
yeah i've been telling the audience that
we're gonna try to get a tiger at the
vegas stage as well so
you know we'll see
a lot of insurance forms on that all
right sophia is going to join us now in
bethlehem pennsylvania sophia how can we
help
hi how are you we're having a blast
oh that's very nice what's going on with
you yes
okay so um i wanted to know how i go
about um you know owning my first home
currently i own a mobile home um and i
just found out it went like up in value
i'm just not too sure whether i should
um rush into getting my own home instead
of um instead of you know staying here
for a couple of years and just saving up
um so i just wanted to know like how do
i go about like getting into my first
home like carefully
because it's you know it's a huge
like step owning a home for sure well
it's a great question and
the idea of you being in more of like a
brick and mortar situation um versus a
mobile home
uh i love just for long-term
value and everything so i think it's a
really smart first step um that you're
even thinking about this sofia so so
kind of our formula that we talk about
when buying a home so this is for your
first home this is for your fourth home
for those of you listening but the
formula is that
to have at least 10 to 20 percent
of it for your down payment saved for a
down payment
and then your payment should be no more
than 25 of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
and so you're gonna go and see you know
what what you can afford and what the
bank will give you um
from from a mortgage standpoint but i
also would warn you sophia that you know
right now obviously the housing cri the
housing market is just it's crazy right
now and
be careful not to get emotional about it
though
because you're gonna see that top dollar
that they're gonna allow you to take out
but i want that top dollar may not be
what you need to take out you may not
need to take out all of that again run
the numbers that formula i just told you
to see okay what what does this feel
like with my
my numbers and my money what's realistic
here um
because the home buying process it is if
you find a home that you love you can
get in this emotional
state and people i just saw stats sophia
literally today that millennials will
pay close to a hundred thousand dollars
over asking price even when they don't
when they don't even if they don't have
the money to do that to get the house
that they want so the bidding war thing
is so true and you get caught up in that
so i would just go with a lot of caution
sofia a lot of caution um yeah um
also because i'm trying to like you know
invest i do have a 401k i i do have a
fidelity account and i i've been
investing in stocks and crypto
so i kind of want to like juggle but i
could still do those things
and
do you have that right now
no i have no doubt and did you say i
thought i heard you say this i'm just
correct i want to make sure i'm correct
on this that your uh mobile home has
gone up in value did you say that at the
start of the call yeah yeah i actually
found out it went up in value i don't
know if it's because what's going on
right now i got it for a really good
price it wasn't expensive
and i just found out um it didn't go up
in value and so you paid cash for it is
that right
yes yes how much is it worth right now
uh about 45.
interesting i i i paid 21.
yeah i got to tell you i've never heard
of a mobile home going up in value one
of the things i would encourage you to
do is let's get some real hard evidence
maybe two or three different real
appraisals on that rachel and the reason
i'm asking that is because uh
selling that mobile home at its height
is a strategy that i would recommend i
don't know what your thought is on this
and then yeah let's put that towards
maybe go down and rent
uh for a bit until she gets that down
payment to where we like since she has
no debt i would also pause all that
investing for the time being to to
really juice that down payment do you
agree with that oh absolutely i mean
yeah i mean if you're in a position
sophia that you're able to sell it at a
tight and you have a buyer and
everything
yeah the kid said go rent an apartment
or something for a year uh pause
everything else save up that for that
big down payment and that that will
really springboard you into that home
buying process yeah i think that's what
i would do there and and and be smart
and again what rachel told you is the
formula and that's going to protect you
one other quick point for those that are
kind of feeling that crunch right now
and rachel's right people are seeing the
escalating house prizes and so what they
do is they go i've got to buy now i've
got to overpay because they're going to
keep going up and i would tell you uh i
think that housing prices are going to
start to cool off and reset at some
point and so patience is the key here
yeah a house
a great house a house that is wonderful
maybe even described as perfect for your
family is still going to be there don't
get sucked into that i've got to buy now
or i'm going to even keep paying higher
prices yes so that's yeah and even the
idea of having options like i feel like
that's one thing yeah i i learned from
my parents they would always say in a
situation but i'm like this is the only
thing this is this is the only way i can
do it like no
pause and look at all of your options so
sophia even bringing in the rent
conversation that ken did that is a
different option you know if you did
find a great deal on a home and you
don't feel like you're overpaying it's
what you wanted and you're able to just
kind of
transfer that money that 45 000 to the
down payment you get that ball rolling
quicker that's great too um there's a
lot of options here but looking at the
wisest thing for you i think if you're
able to if you're able to sell it
at the height of where it's at i'm like
that's i jump on that absolutely you
just think about the exercise run the
exercise of how long if i didn't sell
the mobile home and it is going to
eventually devalue and then you're left
with really not much of an asset at all
so how many months would it take you to
save up 40 000. and that'll help you
with that mental hurdle to go whoo
go get yourself a decent apartment
renting in this case is not throwing
money away no it's being very wise and
i'm very nervous about the crypto
investing because right now all you got
to do don't take my opinion just go pay
attention to the news
watch how that stuff is extremely
volatile right now it's wild
wild it's crazy i wouldn't touch it and
it's something if you want to do later
on down the road because you're
investing in your 401k and roth and you
know you're paying off the house and
you're not you're being smart about
stuff but man i wouldn't dabble on it
right i would not dabble in it right now
if i were you sophia
sophia thank you for the call proud of
you for being debt free stay that way
all right coming up next more of your
calls it's a free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five she's
rachel cruz i'm ken coleman and this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
nashville-based headquarters thrilled to
have you with us i'm ken coleman joined
by rachel cruz the phone number to jump
in is triple eight eight two five five
two two five find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal today's question
comes from devante in chicago i'm a
recent college grad with 50 000 in
mostly student loan debt i'm 25 and i
work two jobs as a delivery job excuse
me a delivery driver
at 16 an hour and another with a local
news program at 14 an hour i'm looking
to grow professionally as a videographer
my skills are in media tv productions
and marketing i've heard many success
stories where people have grown their
videography business and are making over
six figures per year what's your best
advice on how to clear debt and grow my
savings so i can then support myself as
an entrepreneur
it's a great question so the
the debt side of this uh devonte is that
you wanna
we teach the debt snowball so if all of
that fifty thousand which i'm sure it is
broken up into multiple loans
keep them separate and list them out
smallest to largest and you're doing a
great job working your two your two jobs
um but and i think you're at a point
that you're able to live
your your lifestyle extremely low
and so you're going to be doing nothing
nothing except for working which means
you may even add on another job
in addition to these two
and putting everything towards that
student loan and and ideally is that
your skills and everything that ken's
probably gonna talk about here in a
second but that as you grow your
income's gonna grow too so you're not
gonna just stay at this position uh
where you're at it'll take some time
but the point is is to get that income
up where you can and be focused on those
loans because the student loans is the
one type of debt that people just sit
with
because it is so normal and they're just
not in this like urgent state and then
they've even pushed back the student
loan payment even recently this week so
it's like there's not a lot of urgency
so create that urgency in you to put as
much money towards that smallest loan as
possible yeah and the reason i love this
advice devante is paying off the debt
really is the first step
as it relates to you doing the dream job
which is working for yourself as a
videographer once we clear that debt now
we've opened up two main things number
one we freed your finances which takes
off a tremendous amount of stress for
you and now you can invest in yourself
as you walk the baby steps out so we're
going to get that emergency fund which
is gonna be huge that's baby step three
for an entrepreneur having that
emergency fund is so so vital the other
thing it's gonna do for you is is that
mentally uh you're gonna be able to
dream a whole lot more and and be able
to see what a future looks like because
you now realize i can fund my future
it's not such an impossible mountain so
what i would tell you is
do exactly what rachel said i would like
to see you
get to a point where we can make the
same amount of money
in one day job
so you've got two jobs and go gazelle
and get out of debt but i'd like to see
you eventually work for somebody who has
a videography type business so for
instance this local tv job is in that
space be great if you could work
full-time for a local production company
and that one full-time day job pays you
what you were making with the two now
here's the second step
then you begin to do side hustles
contract here or there as a videographer
and begin to build your reputation and
also
company xyz we'll call it that okay the
devantes production company for a
horrible name but we'll begin to put all
that money because now we're debt free
and we have an emergency fund put all of
that side hustle money into the side
hustle bank account and i want to see
you build that up to where you've got
six months of your day job income
in devonta's production company bank
account then
we step into the dream job we don't jump
yes that's how i'd like to see him do
that it's a big deal because i feel like
a lot of people are shifting um oh
entrepreneurial huge i mean it's just
wild so there's a there's a real move
there to be made eventually for sure
which i just love i love seeing that i
love people that are kind of
self-starters
and this is how the baby steps work as
it relates to what we're helping you do
as it relates to work you love the
financial component is massive
you can do them side by side but you've
got to have your financial house in
order all right let's get to the phones
michael is up next in tampa florida
michael how can we help
hey thank you for taking my call um
so i recently have been looking into uh
web development
um
so
right here in the state in florida and i
reached out to the instructor
and when he reached back out
he recommend that i don't take the web
development course because his concern
was
about how competitive my resume would be
versus going for
software engineering which has web
development in
so uh and he's recommending that
um
he's recommending that
i do that
like while i'm in school
i can get a job because web development
the courses are breaking up into pieces
and web development
and it would take me
approximately a year for web development
versus two to four for
the uh associates in software
engineering but i had concerns about
doing that because of my current living
situation like should i go to school
that long should i not
so the end result for you is what truly
to be a web developer
yes
yeah
well there are a lot of ways to get
there what do you mean by your living
arrangements can you be more specific so
i know what you're facing
okay so
me and my wife we still work full-time
um my wife is also in school now well
she works part-time and she's in school
and i still work full-time and we have
five children
so that that forces me to go part-time
and he said part-time
would take me
over approximately almost three years
if i'm in the class is fully online yeah
for software engineering right but web
development would take me a year yeah
well i tell you uh in in my in my
opinion here
um
i think he's giving you some decent
advice
uh except that there are multiple paths
so i wouldn't compare one of those paths
to the other i understand what he's
saying i don't disagree with him but i
also know for somebody who wants to be
in web development and the web
development training is less time and
money i'm going to go do that because
here's what i know
michael relationships are how you get
opportunities
and and so if you want to do web
developing you know taking something
that takes longer and you can only go
part time right now with the five kids
wife's in school i don't want you to
flame out
there's an organization that i endorse
and ramsey solution endorses called
bethel tech i want you to at least call
them they have a nine month online
program nine months
and for ramsey solutions listeners who
can cash flow it okay
you're going to do it for less than
fourteen thousand dollars nine month
program i would look at that based on
where you are now again there's other
competitors kick all of the tires i want
you to look at all the competitors but a
multi-year program right now i don't i
know is not necessary for web
development and you can start in the 70
000 range and maybe even get to a
hundred thousand dollars
it does not take as long and it should
not cost you near as much to do the web
developing versus software engineering
so don't go get a degree or
certification
that includes the one thing that you
want to do when you can go get that one
thing you want to do time and money are
your most valuable resources right now
correct
yes sir so i want you to do your
research i want you to press pause
and get all of the options on the table
rachel because i want to see how that
fits into their financial plan yeah
because here's the deal here's why i'm
saying this michael and i'll give it to
rachel
the work in software excuse me and web
development is always going to be there
i want you to get there the right way
what are you doing now michael well
right now i'm a truck driver okay you
know i
i need um i need an increase because
outside the next step for me in trucking
if i stay in trucking is
going over the road with my own truck
and i can't do that i think i'm already
at the max yeah where i'm at
also i want to add that here in state
um
the instructor i reached out to that web
development course i mean i already have
the cash flow it was a little bit a
little over four thousand dollars
do it
you got the cash yeah do it now and look
at other options too michael he said um
ken said that but go and price out three
other routes as well that would give you
the same outcome again options will give
you power and it'll bring a lot of
clarity and i think this guy did give
you some good advice i would look to are
there some side hustles where i can do
some contract work in web development to
get that resume built up
while you're getting fully certified
you've got this hang in there great job
michael yeah i really appreciate the
call wow he and his wife are getting
after it five kiddos hey you can do it
keep your head down this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by rachel cruz we're here
to help you win in your life
relationally professionally and
financially so it's a free call to join
the conversation triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to la crosse wisconsin where mark
joins us mark how can we help
[Music]
hey guys thanks for taking the call um
to the question
uh before my wife and i got married uh
it'll be 13 years in october congrats we
took the finance piece oh thank you
we had a choice between financial peace
or marriage classes
and i said financial speech she's in
marriage classes we did those
um anyhow um i recently lost my job in
july and
this past
october i got a different job and i've
been listening to you guys on podcast
you
whole point of the question is
since we were married we have had
separate checking and savings account
and then a joint savings for tax refunds
and whatnot um
my question for you guys i recently
listened to
your podcast yesterday
and uh you know talking about combining
everything
um
and i asked her about it and she really
wasn't on board with it because
we've been doing it for so long and it's
not really broken so she's like why do
we need to fix anything that's not
broken so
my question for you just keep doing
things the way we have been um
there hasn't been any real financial
issues
uh
yeah
so
um
uh
pretty much we're almost dead free so
that's awesome congrats yeah you called
rachel can help you with this but i'm
just curious before she dives in here
why you called
asking if it's okay which tells me you
may or may not think it is okay or one
of you thinks it's okay and one of you
doesn't am i right or am i wrong um i i
just i think it's relatively okay but
listen to you guys
and uh previous
podcast um you guys are like really
saying that
marriage is working well it's the best
ideas
so you're kind of wondering all right
tell him rachel yeah and that in that
segment that was with john delonie and
myself yeah we talked about a study um
that we found from the journal of
personality and social psychology and it
talked about how they did a study that
yeah when couples pull their money
together they actually experience
greater relational satisfaction or less
likely to break up
because here's the deal mark now could
the dollars and cents work with how
you're doing it
sure absolutely like i mean you it could
literally like you said nothing's been
broken it could work
but in my what i would argue is that it
could be so much better because the
things that you guys don't even know are
there
and or the things that are not even
being talked about because you are
living in these separate with these
separate checking accounts that's the
stuff that you miss out on because there
is this level of kind of independence
i'm doing your my thing over there
you're doing yours but when you throw
everything together it's like a it's a
clash and a explosion in a good way that
makes you kind of rethink things in a
sense that like man
i she's gonna see that purchase or he's
gonna know that i went there and and not
that you're intentionally trying to hide
anything but there's just this level of
openness that's there
when you have your money together so my
thing would be
yeah it may be working okay
but how much better could it be because
it's going to force conversations that
you're not forced to have right now and
again not even just money conversations
like winston and i we go through our
week to talk about like okay so what
does our evenings look like because we
got to figure out are we picking up
chick-fil-a after the girls gymnastics
or am i cooking like what's happening
and you end up talking about the the out
to eat budget you end up talking about
what's going on in life and calendars
and man this feels really busy right now
i know i'm exhausted i know i i've
missed seeing like you end up in all
these other conversations
that combining your account spring so
it's not just the tactical side of money
that you benefit from but it's the
relational side so that's what i would i
would push you guys on do you feel a
nudge mark to do it to do it differently
i know you heard us talk about it on the
podcast but
do you think it would bring like a level
of of richness that's not there right
now
um i feel like we communicate really
well now um
like we're
the only debt we have is uh truck
payment and um we just talked about it
to knock it out quick and she's putting
money each check and then
it comes directly out of my checking
account and we're just trying to
it's we communicate well to start with
but yeah
like i said i
i get them to hold each other
accountable um
like for example our oldest daughters in
softball so she wouldn't got the better
helmet then i went and got the bag and
the fielding mask so i mean we're pretty
open with each other
about everything but um
um
i think we just trust each other yeah
let me tell you the flip side of this
because we get this call a lot on the
ramsay show couples with separate
accounts rachel
good people well-meaning people
and when you have separate accounts and
you're not really accountable so you
don't know what he has she has whatever
and we get the call we hit separate
accounts and my spouse ran up
tens and tens of thousands of dollars in
credit card debt and i just found out
about it that temptation could hit
anybody i mean nobody's above that yes
so there's no judgment here i'm just
saying that's the reality of this when
we have separate accounts and then one
person goes well i kind of get to do
whatever i want to do in this yeah and
then maybe they get themselves in a hole
yeah we hear about gambling problems we
hear about spending problems we got a
call just last week um uh a a separate
accounts
and the wife found out that the husband
had racked up nearly a hundred thousand
dollars in credit card over legal fees
for custody for a child from a previous
marriage she just found out about it
yeah this is
bone crushing kind of stuff and i would
say too and i would be curious your
thoughts on this can because i this is
how passion i feel about it mark is that
you can go down like that road what ken
just described for sure happens 100
but what what even made me like
kind of like
cringe
is that their daughter plays softball
and she goes and buys part of the
equipment and he goes and buys the other
part you know what i'm saying mark like
like there's just this level of a
division that you're like no no
no we're all supposed to we're all
supposed to go and buy the stuff and it
comes out and it's not a big deal it's
it's the dividing
roommate it's weird really so like wait
wait i'm not trying to say you're weird
like like i want you to hear like a lot
of
a lot of grace in this okay because i
get that it's working and it's almost
the same mindset when people use credit
cards like when i pay it off every month
but i pay it off every month i pay but
you have no idea how much more you're
spending when you have don't have the
emotions attached to your checking
account you don't even know what
conversations you're missing out on mark
and the things that are dividing y'all
because you haven't even done it because
you haven't combined it yet rachel i
think you make an incredible
relationship point
and that is that we are joint we are a
team we're not roommates
i could think of examples for example
but i'll tell you an example that you
made me think of so we have a daughter
josie who's 13 and she and her little
friend
just decided they wanted to start a
bracelet business oh these beads yeah
and i came home the other night and
one of the first things in the door
stacy said hey i gotta let you know
josie came to me today she's all excited
about starting this little business so i
told her we would invest you know we
would buy the first supplies helped her
with pricing all that stuff so this was
a couple's moment where she was just
proud to say this is josie's idea i went
out it was 40 bucks for all the things
yeah yeah it wasn't a accountability
issue but it was this idea that it could
have been shin guards yes cleats right
right
but it was like we had a fun little
conversation i was like that's awesome
yes yes and that's a joint account we
tell each other we can see what we spend
yeah there is you don't even have to
hold someone accountable when you're
just open well that's what i was gonna
say too the accountability thing i
i that even that term i think it does
feel weird to people it's a little
overused too of like i'm gonna keep you
accountable where it's like no i'm
actually gonna just know what's going on
and we're like
mary i can't spend something without her
knowing yes it's fantastic right so that
is built in but i don't feel like ugh
yes yes totally totally so yeah there's
it's a it's a real thing again study
after study another one you know that
one that we just talked about that came
out last week that yeah you just have a
greater level of satisfaction because
you you share everything and and john
delaney made the point and we laugh
about it because i'm like you share your
genetics in a child that's running
around in front of you so like if you
can share your bed if you can share your
refrigerator you share everything share
everything and the money piece it it may
not feel like a big deal because like
you feel like it's just it's on the
track and it's working but i'm gonna
push y'all mark i mean i would and i
would and i would see how your
relationship changes because your
marriage changes when you see yourself
one thousand percent is one totally
agree she's preaching and she's right
she's rachel cruz i'm ken coleman i want
to thank our team in the booth that
makes all this possible to thank you
america because you're the reason we do
the show it is your show it is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relational successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by rachel cruz we
are here taking your calls your
questions this hour the phone number to
jump in is toll free it's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five we know
that this is about real life and so we
know these calls can be sensitive and
private so we'll change your name
location and even some of those details
so that we can
hopefully get you some practical answers
so that you can hopefully move forward i
mean with hope on a very clear path
forward that's why we are here so
excited that you have joined us let's
start it off this hour with tom in tampa
florida tom how can we help
hi uh thank you for taking my call you
bet um
i had a question on uh paying off my
mortgage uh so the wife and i read total
money makeover and
uh we are completely debt free except
for the house wow we have uh two
yeah thank you we have a 290 000 uh
mortgage left on the house
but we do have
uh 163 in mutual funds but we'd have to
pull
190 from
our roth contributions which we are able
uh but wasn't sure if that was uh a good
idea
yeah how old are you tom
are you over 40 you're white i'm sorry
40. you're 40 years old that's a young
man by the way young man young man i
know um
so if there are non-retirement accounts
um
i would consider it but your roth
um i you know
in order to take money out of retirement
you have to be 59 and a half not to be
penalized so i would not touch any
retirement for any reason except for to
to avoid a bankruptcy or a foreclosure
which obviously you guys are not in
um do you guys have
kids uh five oh wow yeah what are their
ages
um
see we got five six
seventeen
eighteen
and uh twenty i'm sorry nineteen and
twenty wow okay so half kind of a step
out of the house and then
two
in that you're get that for a call i'm
just thinking college in my head too
um yes what's your income
uh about 83 a year
okay
but uh with the uh with the question um
as well because uh from my understanding
we could take out of uh roth
contributions that we've made um and and
we can pull from that without taking a
hit but um our our bigger problem is
that we're uh right now we're at about
35
of our take-home for
um
the the mortgage payment so i know
that's well above what what y'all
suggest for 25
yeah yeah we that 25 to 30 for sure is
is where we usually hit i mean i i'm not
i'm not
too concerned about it i still would not
touch retirement though i would not take
money out of
um
out of that retirement and your mutual
fund you you have
163
000 in the mutual fund yeah that's not
not associated with the with the roth
correct we have a total of uh 646 in uh
total investment yeah you guys have done
great that's fantastic i've done an
awesome time uh rachel i i got to tell
you tom
listen i think this is an income thing
this is i got two eyes for you income
and intensity
i think you could make more than 83 and
i think that you can as a result of that
you can increase your intensity on
paying the mortgage off i wouldn't touch
those mutual funds at all you guys i
mean i understand the formula we talk
about but because you guys have no other
debt that's why rachel's not concerned
about that i wouldn't touch that
investment money that is in a good place
you're only 40 years of age
over the next 25-30 years that's going
to be a tremendous amount of money
you've shown great discipline to this
point my goodness five kids
and doing all this i think it's an
income increase and an intensity
increase in paying off the home i i
don't think you need to uh touch that
money that's i wouldn't personally if i
was in your shoes
so
i guess that's that's part of the uh
the question then because i'm a
government employee and
um my wife is
at home with the kids sure so
um increasing the
um
the income would be pretty difficult
only if you stay in the government i
understand that the government's going
to give you those gradual increases and
you largely have no ladder but how can
your talent and skill plus experience
transfer to the private sector where
we're in the hottest job market in the
history of our nation tom are you
interested in looking outside of
government work
uh yes sir
do you suffer with a little bit of doubt
as to whether or not you could cut it or
no one will hire you because you've
worked with the government for so long
no good then what are we waiting on
i'm serious what are you waiting on what
do you do describe what you do the type
of work
um
well i'm a surveyor with prior police
and
other background okay great so can you
think you don't have to list them for me
right now but can you think of three or
four other jobs in the private sector
that uh would allow you to do that kind
of work similar work and even if you had
to get some basic training you could you
could springboard off of this can you
think of two or three things
yes
i can okay great do you have any idea if
you don't it's okay but i want you to
research it do you have any idea what
those pay what those career uh
opportunities are beyond just that
getting in uh what advancement might
look like do you know those numbers
no i don't that's your homework
assignment
i think you got to be able to see what's
out there
okay so let's just say that you can get
a job uh in a uh a local gig you're not
moving the family no uprooting and it's
private sector and you're making a
hundred fifteen thousand dollars would
you jump on that yes or no
it's that's still difficult because the
uh the stability of the the government
job with
that let me tell you something that is a
total lie and i want to set you free
the government stability
is is like saying because it's the
government i'm never going to get laid
off i'm always going to have a place to
work and and that's not true number one
but it's also it that it's saying that
the private sector is risky it's not
risky tom
it's not risky at all if you can provide
value so so i think a couple of options
tom you got you can take
from your original question if you want
to take a little bit out of the mutual
fund to throw out the house to make you
feel a little bit better you could ken
wouldn't touch it at all again we're not
touching any retirement
uh that's that's an option
looking to see is there even getting my
income up is there just a is there a
great opportunity is there a move there
that would take that 35 of your
take-home pay going to your mortgage
down to
25
you know even
29 i don't care but it lowers that
percentage so you guys can actually gain
some traction um or i'll give you a
third option tom because i don't know
and i don't know i mean the housing
market right now is just insane um but
running numbers and looking i don't know
is there another option for your home of
where you could go it's not crazy if it
was 50 of your income
i would be telling you to move uh but
you guys are teetering enough in life
because of your debt free all of it your
income could change depending on a job
move like things can kind of start
happening to get that percentage down so
i'm not worried if you want to throw
some out of the mutual fund to the
mortgage you can but i would just keep
chipping away you're in great shape tom
doing great really are figure out the
best way to pay this mortgage down we
gave you some options and uh please just
look see what could be for you ken wants
you to have a new job tom oh i wanted to
make more money yes because i want him
to pay off that house he's 40. the
market needs it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show so
thrilled that you have joined us it is
all about your life and we want to help
you win i'm ken coleman rachel cruz
joins me this hour in studio and we are
here to take your calls it is a free
phone call triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five rachel and i were
out during the break shaking hands and
and saying hello to folks it's always
nice to see people from all around the
country and i'd like to mention uh we'd
love to have you join us it's free
there's no ticket cost we've got cold
beverages hot beverages
baked goods come see us ramsey
solutions.com we'd love to see it's
always great to see fine folks and got a
great crown out in the lobby today do i
i know it's that spring break i feel
like oh yeah swing through that's right
it is fun though let's get back to the
phones baltimore maryland
home of the orioles and major league
baseball i like the random facts for you
but not you would have not have no i
would have gone ravens that's the only
sporting yeah team i know about well the
orioles are been around much longer so i
had to give them something i bet sam
knows all about it sam are you are you
baseball or football sam
fan
hi hello sam
yeah rachel asked you are you a ravens
fan or a orioles fan or both
i grew up in an orioles fan with cal
ripken and eddie murray that's my guy
that's my guy i can't even say that word
hey sami true story
she's never even heard of the baltimore
warriors until moments ago
that's awesome hey thank you so much for
the call how can we help
well i i hope you can hear me clearly
and god bless you both okay great um you
know i i am the 180 from the last caller
ken i have the proximity principal
sitting in my car next to me
tell someone
go ahead play that needs to be shaped
into something
and
i've had a very difficult battle trying
to shape myself into something that the
market wants to buy if that makes sense
to you okay
why have you
what do you want to do what have you
tried to shape yourself into feels like
there's some intentionality there but it
hasn't worked out what are you been
trying to shape yourself into
well i'd say uh trying to do too many
things and intellectualizing them and
not offering the market one specific
thing has maybe been um a problem for me
good and um that's very good analysis
oh thank you very much well i get glean
wisdom from dave and you guys and
everyone in the bible but um i i have
been too many for too little
and well i probably want your advice for
this to kind of along with your book and
along with the videos and youtube and
everything right to really settle on
something hard into it hey this is for
me i can do it i'm intentional about it
and i wake up every day okay but i have
a trouble marketing myself ken and
whether on linkedin or you know yeah
sam i don't think that's your problem i
think you did a great job of analyzing
your challenge earlier and i think the
marketing yourself is we can i can give
you some techniques and some resources
on that but i think the issue is is
you've tried to be too many things
and in trying to describe yourself to
others you're not really clear and so i
want to simplify this really quick i'm
going to ask you three really simple
questions and i want you to answer them
okay but i'm going to give them to you
one at a time
uh right after another then answer all
three you ready
who are the people you most want to help
what problem do they have or desire and
then what solution or solutions to that
problem or desire do you get most
excited about
offering now answer that for me roll
right through that because i think you
have an answer be super specific i
really
i don't have to answer the first is i
want to help myself now that may sound
egotistical but from the places i've
battled to come up
if i place mental health and physical
health i help so many others when i'm
healthy so okay so again
i appreciate the answer you're being too
pure and i've just found out what's
really going on with you would you if i
interviewed everybody that knows you
would they say that you're an over
analysis kind of guy an overthinker
that would be uh the understatement of
the year that you're not talking to me
right now
you're not talking to sam in baltimore
yes i i
my mind uh i know i mean not that's okay
so sam i didn't ask you that question to
embarrass you i i asked you that
question to set you free because here's
the deal you're talking to somebody who
does that all right so we got to stop
thinking you didn't even answer my
question
who are the people you most want to help
tell me right now who are they
uh the people i most want to help are
people who have been in the same
situation as me so once i rise i will
help them ride i appreciate you're still
not answering you got really close
what are they dealing with those people
that have the same challenges or they've
come through or they're struggling with
what you did what is that tell me
okay i think the people i most want to
help is what the
partners need for helping
like that you broke up we were so close
you broke up who are the people you most
want to help
i think you got me
well i can't understand you
unfortunately so here's what we're going
to do
he's breaking up so bad let me let me
just kind of walk through a couple other
quick steps here and then i'm going to
give you two things sam i'm going to
give you the get clear career assessment
it's a 20-minute assessment that i
created and it's going to give you some
very clear details about yourself just
answer honestly don't ever think then
i'm going to give you from paycheck to
purpose think of these two tools one is
the compass one is the guide up the
mountain but here's the process that i
want you to walk through before you get
these tools
at the end of the day sam you and
everybody else when we find work that we
really love it is always going to be
attached to people
whether directly or indirectly the work
that you do you will see a result from
your work that you can say this is
helping people give an example
somebody could love being a software
developer
and and love that work
and they never really see people that
their software may touch
but they know that if they come to
ramsey solutions for example and they
develop software or they develop a
website or an app
they can see that it is providing
transformation to somebody that they may
never meet
we've got to understand there's always a
direct or indirect connection to people
rachel when we do work and so the reason
i ask those questions because people get
so hung up on a job title i don't care
about job title i don't even care care
about career path i first want to know
who do i want to help
why do i want to help them that's that
problem or desire they have by the way
if you want to design shoes for women
that's a desire
that's just as worthy as solving a
problem so we really want to get behind
what's that personal connection so sam
those are the reasons for the questions
i want you on your own to answer those
questions i want you to stop thinking
put some answers down i want you to get
four or five people in your life who are
truth tellers who know him very well to
check those answers yeah and then take
the assessment and read the book so good
so i have the answer for me but i want
to hear the answer for you great why is
it that you start with
who are the people you want to help that
that's the first
question it's not what's your passion in
life you know what i mean like what
why do you start with that because we
long to make a contribution to this
world like every human i don't care what
your faith is your politics what country
you're from what race everybody wants to
make a contribution to this world so the
reason i ask it in the form of who are
the people you want to help two reasons
number one we we kind of try to shut
their brain down and get their heart to
answer yeah because they will by the way
even the people that struggle on the air
and this is hard to do yeah totally so
this is nerve-wracking but their heart
begins to fill in the answer because
they're connected to a person and it's
almost always
connected to past pain whether we
experienced the pain directly or we saw
someone else go through the pain for
about two or three minutes we find that
what was really going on they had the
idea but they needed validation that hey
they had what it took to be able to do
it so i start with people first
and then i'm trying to drive deeper into
well you told me these people you want
to help them what's that specific
problem or two that you get excited
about yep yep so good that's why we do
that i want to turn our brains off
because when you start thinking about
job future career path that's
intimidating yeah and i understand that
and you know this i teach this i want
people to know there's a lot of people
new to to all of us ramsey personalities
from time to time
i don't believe there's just one dream
job for everybody i believe that you and
i are both in our dream jobs but i also
know there are other dream jobs what
makes that true any job where i can use
my talent what i do best to do work i
love that's passion to produce results
that directly matter to my values that's
your simple dream job description so
loosen up engage the heart sam hang on
the line we're going to get you some
great resources good luck to you sam
you're a great guy so pure and boy do i
understand overthinking
i'm an over overthinker in the hall of
fame hey don't move rachel and i aren't
going anywhere don't you because more of
the ramsay show is coming up right
around the corner
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined by
rachel cruz and we are here to take your
phone calls you want to win financially
you want to win relationally you want to
win professionally sure you do how can
we help
we are here for you breakthrough is one
phone call away triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to tampa
florida nathan is on the line nathan how
can we help
hey how you guys doing today we are
having a blast what's going on with you
uh good good i'm actually calling with a
pretty a good problem to have okay
i just got accepted into grad school i
got accepted into two programs and i was
hoping if i could get some
financial advice because i want to make
a good decision and pick a track that
will
be in a field that's more lucrative in
the long term
i got accepted into a strategic
intelligence program and a project
management program and i'm going on a
free tuition waiver because uh i worked
at the school that i got accepted to
nice and i'm just trying yeah so uh so
right now i'm in between baby steps
three and four so you know building up
my emergency fund um investing in my
retirement and i just want to make the
best decision to go into a field that
kind of sets me up better in the long
run so
i suggest as to what i should do from a
career aspect that's a great question so
i want you to describe the first the pm
i know project management what was the
first one you said and give me like a
little bit of detail around that
it's an msn strategic intelligence so
things like uh counterterrorism um i can
work for like the fbi or wow
okay so like
that's kind of where i thought my head
when i thought or a project manager
those are two very different routes
nathan
so the question has to be yeah which one
are you leaning towards which if you
look at the paths that those uh specific
areas of study open up which one is most
attractive to you just the feeling it
just feels better when you think about
it
um i'm peter and i'm right at 50 50 um
mainly just because i i like to make my
decisions based on where i think the
industries will go in the future
all right hold on i set myself up best
financially all right you're a smart guy
and you're crushing it by the way let's
remove your brain for a second because i
got great news for you
um project management is one of the most
versatile
uh studies of discipline it's extremely
versatile in that you can do project
management for so many different
industries so many different types of
organizations and then even more
exciting about project management
there's a ladder for you to grow i mean
you can really move up into an executive
level over time by continuing to deliver
as a project manager so i want to tell
you something that's a fantastic path
and then the other path kind of call it
counterterrorism maybe even artificial
intelligence cyber security
yes that's where i go yes action star i
forgot to mention that that'll pay you
20 million a film uh so there you go
i mean both of those have tremendous
upside so let's remove
because i heard what you did and i like
your i like the way you answered that
you're very strategic let's shut the
logic down because i think i've made the
case both of those are great financial
opportunities for you
so let's remove that what is your heart
most interested in in either one of
those paths
oh well i got my undergrad in a sport
management um and i always wanted to go
back to that field but i i learned
quickly with covid and entry level that
the pay wasn't there the opportunity
wasn't there part of why i moved to
florida
and i would love to get back into that
field and i feel like both industries
could get me back there someday so i'm
more leaning along the lines of where
campbell will be in the next 10 years
what field would i want to be in you
know well if you want to get back into
sports management which is essentially
be a sports executive one day am i right
yes i would go the project management
route because the counterterrorism is
very that's a different that's a whole
different ball game are the skills
transferable is the experience
transferable i think you can make that
case
but if i want to get into sports
management
i want to prove that i was a really good
numbers process systems guy because
that's what they're looking for these
big time pro organizations all of them
now have entire staffs that largely
don't know much at all about what
happens on the field or the court but
they're crunching numbers they're
looking at data so if that's where you
want to go i would lean towards project
management rachel yeah i mean that's
your end game because that's what i'm
trying to figure out because i think
both i think it's smart to ask okay so
what are the each industry where is it
going to be
um but
i mean i think
both cases i think you're fine nathan i
think it's just to say hey in 10 years
what would your perfect world be what
would you be doing and what are the
things that you can do to get you there
but you're still how old are you nathan
uh 23 years old yeah i was going to say
i feel like you're still young and in a
great way um
to say god you have so much so much time
ahead of you even if you changed courses
nathan in 10 years oh it's okay good
very good point can i ask you why you're
so hung up on being in tampa for a long
period of time tampa's great love tampa
got friends there originally i'm from
connecticut so i wanted to get out of
the cold but the biggest thing is like
camp is the big economic you know hub
right now innovation hub so when i got
an opportunity to work with the school i
knew they had like the employee tuition
waiver i know you guys are big on
avoiding debt so i'd be able to finish
my master's debt free good so i i just
wanted to be here and involved in
everything going on so here's my point
my footing i was going to play older
brother for a moment
don't limit yourself to tampa you know
with the training and what you're going
to be doing i love that you're doing
this debt free the the the best do the
schooling here
but open your mind up to multiple
markets throughout the country for
opportunities tampa is not your only uh
place that you can be successful so i
listen i wouldn't give up on the sports
management but i do like the
non-traditional route and i love the the
project management is probably which way
i would lean but rachel's right both of
these are fabulous industries that pay
well and and provide for advancement
so i like that it's a great question
what a sharp young guy
no debt
and see rachel this is very interesting
here's a guy who figured this out he's
like now if i go here and i do this
i can get master's level education
for zero dollars it's amazing absolutely
incredible yeah i love that there's so
many
33 year olds nathan that wish that they
were you at 20. isn't that the truth
yeah that is so true all right let's go
next to burlington vermont landon is on
the line there landon how can we help
hi there rachel lynn ken how are you
guys today doing great how can we help
so three short pieces of background i am
currently a university of vermont
student my major is computer science
minors in stats and math i will be
graduating in may
um
and then uh second second piece for you
is that um i just got married in july
2021 to my lovely wife sarah nice
congratulations
thank you and then finally the third
piece of background is that we are
currently on
baby step four because i was fortunate
enough to go to uvm for one dollar
one because of a calculation mistake in
a grant but otherwise it's been fully
covered with a massive blessing massive
blessing from the lord
and uh
i i guess our question for you today is
we are both very interested
do you understand what he said because
of a clerical error
uh on some grant paperwork sorry sorry
i it was it was i just got charged one
dollar because of a little calculation
error but otherwise it was my grand that
covered me
oh okay the way it sounded is if
somebody made an error and you you got
to hold them to it you only went for a
dollar that's what i thought okay
so what's your question anyway my my
question is uh we are both very
interested in having a family in the
future in the near future and we are
interested in buying a house but i'm
wondering whether we should prioritize
saving up for a 20 down payment first or
prioritize retirement savings
yeah that's a great question um i would
say for you guys where you're at you
you're gonna be graduating in may
newly married all that are y'all gonna
stay in the area that you're at
currently are you guys looking to move
is that gonna depend on the job what's
your plan in the next six months
so funny what you ask um we are
interested in moving uh one of the
places that i just applied to mostly out
of state jobs is what i'm applying to
but i just actually applied to ramsey
solutions yesterday ah
that's cool landon maybe we'll see you
in nashville so i would say depending on
i would wait pause
figure out what city you guys want to
live in figure out the job situation
wait a year rent you're fine
and then press play on statement for the
down payment and then retirement but
just pause for a year if you want to go
ahead and open up a roth or something
you can do that but i would wait to buy
a house
i love that advice and you're already in
baby step four so you're off and running
good for you appreciate the question
wow will landon make it to ramsey
solutions i don't know we won't be able
to answer that anytime soon
don't move we can't answer your
questions coming up this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
um
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by rachel cruz thrilled to have
you with us the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five all right rachel a
very interesting phenomenon going on
right now
of
what they're calling boomerang employees
all right so kind of set the context for
this
since august of 2021
uh leading up to the jobs report in
march we've had over four million plus
people changing jobs each month that's
crazy so we're hurdling towards 30
million people that have changed jobs so
that's one factor all right a lot of
people
leveling up getting a big bigger
paycheck as a result
we've got the lowest unemployment rate
we've ever seen 3.4 percent and so
there's this hiring war that is going on
i mean we see it uh we we we showed a
picture of a it went viral
on the ken coleman show a picture of a
panda express that was offering sixty
eight thousand dollars to a manager of a
panda express plus tuition
plus plus plus oh my gosh uh we also
showed a recent taco bell hiring sign
that said cell phone breaks included
so instead of smoke
this is for the younger generation they
don't want to smoke a cig they want to
go you want to scroll instagram check
tick tock and instagram tick tock so
you're way cooler than i am well
no i'm not great
you like drop that in there yeah they
want to scroll so
so what's happening is there's big push
for hiring so companies are losing
people to somebody else and and
employees are going hey i can get a 20
bump i don't blame them right so they go
right so boomerang employees are two
types of people some of those people who
left jobs rachel in that 30 million are
already realizing that the grass was not
greener to use an old old phrase they
got there recruiters may have sold them
a bill of goods whatever and they go
it's not what i wanted to be and even
though i got the bump i don't like it
can i go back home that's one boomerang
employee and then the second one
is the employee who left prior to the
pandemic maybe three four five seven
years ago yeah but because of technology
facebook
linkedin whatever
people stay in touch longer and better
and so companies are now in this
employee
uh they they're like they can't find
anybody and they realize wait a second i
wonder if joe who left us seven years
ago would want to come back
interesting so the employer is reaching
out that too so we have two things going
on employers reaching out to past people
who left well meaning they didn't burn a
bridge sure sure uh and then uh these
people who have left and realized it's
not as good as i thought it was going to
be can i come back and so i know in an
audience this large
there should be no shame in your game is
the is the phrase
if you made a decision and you left well
and you feel like the relationship's
still there
and it's not working out
swallow your pride yeah i i'd go check
and then if the company comes calling
for you and you feel like you're hey man
you know what i'll go back i just think
it's interesting it's called the
boomerang employee thoughts on that well
it's funny because the boomerang
generation yeah right was a whole other
thing
when i was in school
and you would come back and live and
live back at home but the boomerang
employee i'm curious how many people
left jobs specifically just for a higher
salary higher pay
that are
unhappy yeah we don't have the data i
know but i would be curious i i would
love to see if anyone out there if that
was you
because i just want to i just i'm
fascinated because that's a big thing
because it is so competitive out there
very competitive and if you love the
place that you work
but man someone's going to offer you
yeah 15 20 grand more yeah
your mind says okay
right like yes so here's a really quick
caution to those of you who don't want
to become boomerangs right you know okay
so what do we do all right let's
understand what happens psychologically
when somebody a recruiter reaches out to
you or a friend says hey my company's
hiring are you interested and that
company shows interest and they offer
you a job two things happen that are
really hard to overcome
the first thing is you get offered a job
and it's more money that
that feels good
it's like whoa i got more money i'm
gonna be able to do this this this this
yeah i've already spent it in my heart
the second thing that happens is it
looks good we get to tell our co-workers
our friends and family hey i uh had a
recruiter reach out and uh they offered
me a job don't we all want to be wanted
so there's two big psychological things
that you got to be careful
it's almost like the old advice to sleep
on it two or three days so that you
don't make a decision based on the
feeling because that check
feels good bigger check and then the
promotion looks good it's a little
status
because this is your world i don't live
in the sure in this world the career
world um but
how many how how have you felt like this
has been because the numbers are
staggering 30 million in just like four
months or something right have changed
like it's just crazy
so what are you what are you seeing are
you seeing that people are branching out
they never would have because they you
know maybe the money is enticing and
they actually are thriving
are they finding a setback or they like
do you know what i mean i'm curious it's
still so unstable well
it it will eventually calm down it'll
cycle out but i don't know how soon it's
going to cycle out here's what's driving
it i think the majority of people are
moving because the pandemic created an
opportunity for them to level up they
just flat out said you know what i'm not
treated like i'm super valuable this is
a function of poor leadership and how
employees have been treated for a long
time so they're going wait a second
i don't feel valued i don't feel like
this is super meaningful work so i am
gonna take
that immediate hit which is a bigger
paycheck
show me the money you know the classic
line from i think that's one and i do
think that there are a lot of people
that a little bit more on where i'm
focused is helping people do something
that matters i do think that the
pandemic brought on a massive change so
people got more comfortable with change
which they're not normally comfortable
with number two
mortality set in mm-hmm they were
looking at death numbers scrolling on
the screen every day and i think you
start to go what am i doing with my life
yeah so because two things happened one
people started looking for work that
they would really enjoy to go after and
then we saw entrepreneurial starts so
the numbers have been record numbers of
people starting small businesses working
for themselves yes so all that's in that
same thing because there's a flexibility
aspect too that people look for more
these days than they did
20 people vowed that they would never go
back to the office again they said if my
company makes me come back yeah i'm not
going back very very interesting let's
get back to the phones julie is joining
us in san antonio texas julie how can we
help
hi there i actually have kind of a
unique question i am on
baby step six
and on track to pay off my home in the
next two years
and i'm scratching my head asking myself
when am i going to have fun
i've been you know paying off all this
debt
and concerned that i'm paying off the
house but the house does need some
repairs and i i find myself wobbling
between do i
want to pay off a house that needs
repairs because i'm not using any money
for the repairs or do i need to save
some money and get a new house it's just
it's really funny i mean i've enjoyed
this whole process yeah but now i i
don't even know how to spend money
anymore it's kind of interesting no we
hear that a lot for sure especially if
you've been like very motivated on it
because we tell people once you pay off
debt and you have your emergency fund
you can
kind of let your foot off the gas you
know and it's more looking ahead uh it's
not as that gazelle intensity that we
talk about maybe steps one through three
um so how how much will the house
repairs
cost the house repairs will probably run
about 30 000 okay how much is your house
worth
the house is worth about 260. okay do
you like the house are you happy where
you're at
i i am happy with the neighborhood i'm
happy with the house
however i do see that there there's some
improvements needed sure um and i'm i'm
nervous to spend money
honestly so it's more prepared yeah it's
more of that how much do you have left
to pay off you said you have two more
years
yeah if i keep going the way that i'm
going i have a hundred and fifteen
thousand
to pay off nice and are these repairs
urgent are the things that like really
need to be done now or you just see hey
and
in the next little bit i probably need
to start fixing some stuff
no they're not urgent i've done some of
the debt that i've paid off with the
urgent repairs okay okay
they're not urging that's great well i
mean julie
two years
is is pretty fast so i would pay it i
would go ahead pay off the house save up
money do the repairs
um and all that and just force yourself
to do it say i my house needs to be i
can spend this money it's good money
being spent you're not just going crazy
with it um but i would do that go
because when you don't have a mortgage
you're gonna be able to save up so that
30 000 so much faster than you will
right now i love it and since they're
not urgent i take a little fun vacation
then come back and deal with all those
repairs there you go you've earned it
you're gonna pay your house off way to
go congrats julie hey rachel cruz thank
you thanks to our team in the glass
appreciate you thank you america this is
the ramsey show
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
rachel cruz we are here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's toll free triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we know that life is hard
and yet we know that there is a way to
overcome those challenges and move
forward
to live the life that you desire we want
to help you do that let's go emily is
going to start us off in rio rancho new
mexico emily how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call you bet
what's up
so my son is getting ready to turn 18
and we
talked about
switching our will that he would get the
three
other three children in the event that
my husband and i passed and he wants
them but
i just don't know if that's like way too
much to put on a kid
oh
my my knee jerk is yeah
his entire life would be
paused and he'd be taking care of three
kids how old are the kids the other kids
uh 15
14 and 10.
why why him i'm curious why him
right now we have him with us my sister
but
her marriage is
pretty rocky and so we've just never had
peace
and
he wants them is what brought it up
he's a
he's a freak of a kid i mean he's like
the best boy he's always been such a
great kid super responsible
he almost has his associates
so yeah he sounds incredible i mean to
even have this conversation and make it
an option
i can only speak to it from
having three kids and we did this
many years ago
before i was even working with dave dave
said you know i follow what dave teaches
and so we put our will together when we
had our first
and um
in our situation um we chose stacy's
sister and and my brother-in-law
obviously they're a much healthier
situation than what you've got but we
had three or four other options
and um and i'm just curious if you do
you have other options even if they're
not family but they're stable friends
that you know would take care of the
kids until a certain age
yeah we do have friends that we
would definitely
love them to go to it's just um
yeah is it okay to tell him no we don't
want to put that like i mean because he
wanted them
he's so kind but i mean i would say
i would say i mean of course it's okay
to tell him though yeah i mean as your
mom
i want to
say how thankful and grateful and how
close
you can still be to them right if god
willing right we're hoping none of this
happens this is a worst case scenario
situation um but if something were to
happen he can still have
a close relationship with them and even
with the friends having their permission
to still live with them if that's what
they he wants but to be able to still
have the ability to have other options
in life and at 18
he right i think your frontal global
cortex isn't even completely uh for guys
it's 25 24 or 25 right you know what i'm
saying so like as his mom i think you're
loving him very well that he can still
be as involved
with them uh because because let's be
honest too only if something were to
happen to you and your husband
i would pray that the siblings become
closer right that like like you
so you just went through tragedy so you
guys are going to hopefully
um that brings you together especially
at these ages but i wouldn't put the
responsibility i mean he'll have to be
the you know the executor of the will i
mean he would do a lot
and at 18 i just wouldn't it's more of a
burden than a blessing i think but i i
agree with rachel and when he turns 21
23 you know maybe in like four years you
can even change it where the 10 year old
is i just don't think he needs to be
legal guardian i love what you said i
think he's big brother he's their hero
he's their number one influencer he's
intimately involved but he's not the
legal guardian yeah let another couple
who their parents and they are
responsible and they can make the big
legal decisions things of that nature if
there would be a trust involved that 10
year old
10 or 14 they're not driving he would
have to be he would have to be and even
at 21 22 23 i think it's still too much
yeah it's true it's true that's a good
point i i would say hey you're amazing
kiddo oh my goodness blown away we're
going to set you up to where if this
awful horrible worst case scenario
happened it would not in any way impede
your life
goals yes
that would be the reason to tell him no
and explaining why
well what a what an interesting call
thank you so much for the call what a
what a great young man that is let's go
now i wasn't asking for my
siblings you that's the truth
yikes uh let's go to russell now who
joins us in tampa florida russell how
can we help
uh good afternoon ken thanks for taking
my call sure what's up i have a little
bit of a little complicated situation i
got um head hunted by a buddy of mine
that worked for a consulting firm
and they've offered me a job that is
sixty thousand dollars more than i make
a year wow
which sounds great
but here's the problem is i work for a
government entity and they're going
through a really tough time now
and i know that i am
crucial
if not
almost europe
irreplaceable in the situation that they
have
i put my notice in because i was
expecting to take the job and then
they've come back and they've offered me
more money to where the delta is only
35k a year now and then
they've also offered me a vehicle to
take home which is worth i don't know
about 10 or 15k
um so i guess i have a crisis of
conscience here right where where i i
love where i work i love who i work with
but the opportunity is also something i
love as well so yeah okay all right this
is great more situations at the end yeah
yeah yeah that's good um
if if you weren't so crucial to them
you and they weren't going through a
tough time would you have been calling
me with this wrestling match of your
head and heart
i would not no
so so let me let me absolve you from
what you feel is guilt and there's
nothing the word guilt comes up a lot in
these situations
the word guilt has a legal connotation
and it usually applies to a jury saying
that somebody broke the law
are you breaking the law if you take
this great opportunity russell
i am not no all right let me ask you
another question are you doing anything
unethical
no you're not that's cool but no so hold
on a second yeah it's a government
entity they were around before you
joined them they will be around
and if they weren't gonna make it with
you or they're struggling to make it
with you they will struggle to make it
without you i'm trying to set you free
you're a great young man you're a great
guy the very fact that you called with
this tells me you are so classy and and
you need to go do what's best for you
it's a government organization they're
all horribly run yeah but he loves it
doesn't matter he also said this other
opportunity i know better yes he loves
the people yes but this is a better one
i feel obligated to take care of it but
you shouldn't feel like that's what
you're saying yes yes take the right
opportunity for you and your life be
classy
but take the right opportunity here's
why the very people you're afraid of
hurting and upsetting you will
eventually resent if you don't take this
opportunity i would rather disappoint
people than resent people there you
there's a word for the day big
difference russell congratulations take
the job today
tell the government thanks but no thanks
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america you have joined the
ramsay show so excited that you have i'm
ken coleman rachel cruz joins me in
studio this hour as we take your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five okay
uh i don't know if you're like me rachel
i'm sure a lot of these people out there
that are watching and listening are sick
and tired of this inflation uh number
one we're tired of seeing it uh in our
pocketbooks we're seeing it at the
grocery store we've seen it at the gas
station we're seeing it everywhere
and we're tired of hearing about it and
talking about it all the excuses one way
that's like what's going on but it has
some real life effects
and the fact of the matter is it's got
to be changing budgets if you're not
changing that budget out there it's
going to really bite you but in the
other side of things while it's never
fun to see prices rise we can't budget
through this yes
yeah absolutely i mean it hurts it's not
fun you're like man
so uh the average american budget
is gonna go up or i should say they
should budge the average american should
budget for an extra fifty two hundred
dollars this year according to bloomberg
uh the business insider put out an
article about this and so i think that's
so fascinating that 2200 of the 5200
is food energy all of that so it goes so
it comes down to about for an extra 433
dollars a month which is substantial
it's a lot it's a car payment it's what
it feels like you know wow so
this is if you've not been intentional
with your paycheck up until this point
if you've not been budgeting if you've
not said okay i am going to watch every
single dollar now's the time to do it
this is the kind of thing that if you
just don't really look up and you go
that this this is the time too where
people you know have credit cards and
like oh i paid off every month
but you slowly start racking stuff up
and then you know you look back and
you're like oh my gosh we how did this
happen so you have to be intentional you
guys you have to and the budget it's
going to help you do that and you're
going to probably say no to certain
things that you've said yes to in the
past until this kind of clears but also
the flip side we've talked so much about
jobs and careers i feel like in the show
with you
the flip side is true too that that
wages are going up as well it may not be
completely correlated obviously but
um
but it but i mean it's it's getting to
the point
options when the wages go up
we tend to think oh we can spend more
and so there's just natural so if
there's no natural discipline no natural
budgeting the lifestyle creep it's the
lifestyle group very well said you know
it's funny i was i was in los angeles uh
last couple days doing some work and uh
i was in the airport and i was noticing
i'm starting to pay attention to things
that i didn't pay attention to in the
past the old snack the old snack for the
cross-country flight oh yes it's crazy
how expensive it's gone up yeah stuff
the four was like a couple bucks and now
it's like four or five bucks yes totally
totally so you know we we're having a
little bit of fun with that but you
start doing that over groceries that's
right oh yeah and everything else can
catch you quick so wow wow so hey uh
every dollar shouldn't we be telling
about that i feel like yeah oh yeah it's
the it's the best budgeting app i check
it every day literally transact your
transactions come in you you connect
your bank account and you watch it and
you know exactly what is going on and
again it's never fun to
make the sacrifice or just like gosh
we're gonna just eat in yeah tonight and
you know it's it's not fun to make some
of those decisions but at least you're
in control and as this passes that
you're not more in a financial hole
um
than when you started so you've said it
many times a budget gives you permission
to spend that really connects to people
we hear that all the time every dollar
is the budget app wherever you get your
apps check it out ramseysolutions.com
phenomenal budgeting tool that for those
of you who've never done it before it
will really help you get started you're
going to skin your knees a few months as
you figure it out but we do recommend
that you check it out let's go to
columbia missouri where amanda joins us
amanda how can we help
yes hi i'm so glad to be talking to you
guys today well we're happy to talk to
you what's up
yes we are a dual income family with
three kids age five years three years
and four months old we're on baby step
four five and six
and right now our 15-year mortgage is
less than 25
of our take-home pay wonderful however i
desperately want to quit my high-stress
job and
do a stay-at-home mom or part-time
but if i do that
only on my spouse's my husband's salary
our mortgage goes up to like more than
almost 40 percent of our take-home pay
it's just not doable for us
so my question
is should we consider a refinance of our
home or
uh consider moving or consider just
paying it off with gazelle intensity
before a career change or
quit how many years do you have left on
the 15 year
we have about 13. okay yeah do you do
you love the house amanda
we are quite partial to it we've cash
flowed remodel of the house it's two
doors down from my parents oh yeah yeah
what's causing this job to be so high
stress
um
uninterested and
massive amounts of mandatory overtime
what's your take home i mean what's your
gross salary or gross pay
it's about
close to 67. what do you do
i work for a major insurance company as
a claims specialist
rachel i i i mean
i'd like to see you i'd like to see you
look at changing jobs and it doesn't
necessarily have to be 67 for a dollar
67 000.
maybe it's a little bit less money but
it's a whole lot more enjoyable and
again i mean if you could replace it
with a with a job making the exact same
money and you really enjoy it that'd be
great to go ahead and knock this house
out um but i know you want to be home um
and and and so i think at this point
selling the house is not a good move i
think it's a different place of work
feels like the best fit right now
yeah it's that or amanda you know it's
we're in april right now
so maybe you say hey for three months
i'm gonna work and we're gonna put my
paycheck in a separate
separate account over here
and live off of
your husband's salary and and to say
okay what would life feel like
give it a shot of what of what this
would be because i know as a mom like
and i go through the amanda like these
seasons from like i should be home with
my kids like
um
and if that's if that's where you're at
and that's where you're like man this
would be this is part of getting out of
debt like you guys are at the point in
the baby steps where you're able to make
big life changes because you've done the
hard work you don't owe anyone anything
yeah you have this mortgage we'd love
the house to be taken care of but man
uh to be able to make these decisions in
life that you want to make and be home i
would love for i would love to see you
do that unless you kind of still want to
work and what ken was saying earlier
would that would fit perfect we're like
man there could be a side thing i could
bring in some money because i think i'd
go crazy if i was home all day like i
don't know where you're at but um but i
would give it a test run through the
summer
and then um because your kids are still
little so summer is
12 months a year right like i feel like
it's true it's not like you have
elementary school kids so so you've had
the numbers that's where the three in
day care gets a little yeah
wait a second wait a second wait a
second so i'm assuming
that you've run all these numbers but
rachel makes a very good point of kind
of test running thing but let me ask you
this what's the monthly uh bill for
three kids in daycare round round
numbers
um it will be around
pretty i have a pretty reasonable person
for 1500 a month
okay okay so so right there so have you
run the numbers i'm guessing you have
but i guess i should ask are you running
the numbers to where you could say
because you said there's no way we could
do it on my husband's income do you know
that for a fact
yes but the mortgage just jumped up
with taxes and insurance to
1285 and
with daycare is 1500 and then his income
is about
the actual take-home pay is like 3 300 a
month okay but what if what if we change
those numbers just right here on the air
real quick and we put the 1 500 back
into the old pot because you're not
having to pay that you could definitely
do it could you not
you're at home
not even working from home you're just a
mama
yes and his monthly take-home of 3 300
would be about
the mortgage would be
right now 12.85 it just went up to right
but my point is that that 1500 you guys
could definitely do that without paying
that child care
yes or no yeah
yes i had considered also trying to pay
off the house real fast because we only
owe 114 on it
and since i have
ability to do overtime it's almost
doable
well you got a couple of options there
it's what you guys want it's a values
question at this point for you do you
want to be home more you want the house
paid off
faster what do you want more of and
that's that's only a question you guys
can answer we just made that budget a
lot fatter with 1500 bucks because she's
now at home with the kiddos
maybe that's a season she could always
get another job she's stressed out they
start school again maybe you go back i
like rachel's test idea let's say 1500
bucks a month for three straight months
just by being at home she doesn't like
the job anyway this is the ramsay
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman i'm joined by my colleague
rachel cruz and we are here for you tax
season is ending soon oh geez i wish
that were true does it ever end
of course filing taxes is what we're
talking about but i am just so put out
with all the taxes uh but anyway if
you're filing online which is about 95
of you you need to find affordable tax
software that you can trust and that's
hard to do when so many companies claim
their tax software is free and then they
end up charging you somehow some way so
don't put up with that nonsense try
filing with ramsey smart tax it's super
easy to use and you'll get every federal
form you need with no hidden fees right
now you can even use promo code tax 22
to get 25 off filing your federal tax
return that means you get our federal
classic software for free or
you can get our federal premium software
with priority support and a financial
coaching session all
for just 20 bucks so if you're ready to
file your taxes with confidence go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart tax to get started today that's
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
smart tax derek is up next in omaha
nebraska derek how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely
well i had a kind of another mortgage
question i know the last question was
about mortgages um mike i'm 31 years old
from omaha and uh we have about 370
thousand dollars left to pay on our
mortgage
uh it's 15-year mortgage we're so we're
a year into this
and we only have a two and a quarter
interest rate so it's fairly low it's
about as low as you can get i think and
i was thinking
should i be investing when we get out of
debt or should we probably try to pay
off that earlier than 15 years because
that's a really low interest rate
compared to what you could probably get
on an investment
uh it's true so we want you to do both
so we talk about funding 15 of your
income into retirement
and if you guys have kids starting kids
college and then throwing the rest at
the house
so
what i and i hear you 100 because when
you look at the numbers and you run the
numbers out sure you can make more in an
investment versus paying off the
mortgage i hear i hear that um
but the problem that we have found
over decades of doing this and talking
with people
is personal finance it's not always
about the numbers there's a level of not
having a mortgage
having zero risk in your life
that changes the game and there's not a
number for that feeling of
you don't owe anyone anything because
when you don't have a mortgage
you can do it i mean you can do whatever
you want you have no payments and in
fact you could take that mortgage
payment and invest and invest that if
you wanted to so so there's a peace of
mind there is a change of heart a change
of spirit something happens
when you don't owe anyone anything and
that's why we're just big on
even paying off the house so
the math this interest rate versus that
if you invest it or what you're paying i
mean all of that
um i get it in an intellectual just math
side could that work out yes
but you never factor in life you never
factor in things that can happen you
never factor in
the peace that comes with not owing
anyone anything so so i want you to do
both derek i want you to do both i want
you to fund retirement and you guys are
still young which is awesome
pay off the house early and then you're
going to have your entire income to do
whatever
whatever you want yeah i mean they're on
a 15 year that's fantastic yep you're
doing great they're going to knock it
out yeah keep on going the reason why
dave put the baby steps in order is
because
they need to be in order and so rachel's
right baby step four that 15 you are
investing now knock out that every extra
dime that you can knock it out you're
going to do it faster than you could
possibly imagine i mean the amount of
money we see from debt free screamers
that come in here and they pay off in
four or five years oh it's packaged
is the average right now for people on
the baby steps paying off their house
yeah so wow i mean seven years from now
that's the vision derek seven years ago
and you're not even 40. i know seven
years from you know what i'm saying like
you have so much time so much time on
yourself i'd appreciate if you wouldn't
act like 40 is like the way you said
that i'd appreciate if you'd say that a
little differently you're not even
you're not even 40 like like he's going
to have a cane when he's 40. geez for
those of us that are older than 40 it's
just man maybe it's stunning he's just
feeling it feeling again kidding
over there what'd you
rachel what'd you say huh turn your mic
up
what's happening all of a sudden we
turned into like characters you're
you're not even 40. that was an
inflection of
you're still so i know i'm faking it's
all fake outrageous thanks it's all fake
news i got you all right eric is up next
in boston massachusetts erica how can we
help
hi um so i have a question regarding
both my spouse and i being spenders
we have
three beautiful kids um ages six two and
four months
and i've been
using the every dollar budget about two
three months now
and it just seems like we keep going
over budget i'm spending on stupid
things and you know i'm just sick of
being stupid about it i'm sick of not
being content
with what god has given me and um
i'm sick of acting pretty much like a
child
with our money and um i just want us to
be adults about it yeah um i want to see
adults with our money
and you know like my mom's been trying
to help me to like stay on track but you
know i don't want to put that burden on
her um so i've been calling her when i'm
feeling vulnerable about the spending
and she's been trying to help me through
it um
however i just want to know like for
some things that i can do like on a
daily basis on a weekly basis that can
help change the behavior um because that
seems to be the problem like i'm really
good with that in the budget and where
to go with like stuff in my envelopes
um
and how does it how is it what can i do
to help the behavior
so two things that come to mind my first
question is is your budget realistic are
you
setting a budget that is realistic with
your lifestyle erica like are you you
know i know this is a extreme example
but you're not putting like 50 for food
it's a reason it's a reasonable budget
it is and i guess like a little leeway
so i give he gets 80 a month to spend
and i get 80 a month
okay okay so my next question would be
what is causing you to spend what are
the things that are coming up that
you're spending and then you're
regretting
and you're thinking man i just want to
be content you know i heard you say that
so so what are the things are do you
guys have good community around you are
you lonely are you you know what what
what is the emotion i think he's just
like hobbies so like he canceled his gym
membership so we got a really basic like
dumbbells and like a bench so that we
can set up in the basement and you can
do it in the basement yeah um and then i
i like to garden and like i just i've
always wanted um to get just like you
know just little pots so i can plant my
seeds and that's literally sure what we
overspent on this month and it's just
like those little hobbies so that we can
enjoy our home without having to spend
going out yeah yeah and it's just so
stupid when i like think i get that like
fire's remorse about it because it's
like i have three little babies
depending on me and i can't live this
way anymore
and i just wanted to stop yeah
absolutely well i hear it in your voice
erica and and and i don't want
it it feels like um
you have so much shame and so much guilt
of it which part of it i i understand
because you feel like you're making the
same mistake month after month so you're
frustrated with yourself so i hear that
but i also want to relieve you to say
like everyone screws up erica like at
nobody even even us sitting behind this
desk every ramsey show like nobody's
perfect when it comes to money so
they're going to be mistakes
um so are you guys tell me more about
your situation how much how much debt do
you guys have how much do i make a year
so we have about like fifty thousand
dollars like that okay um
most of it like um
30 of it is my my school loans which
he even took on an extra job um so that
we can pay that off more and put it in
600 a month plus what he's getting paid
on his side job okay what's going on
what's the other 20 what's the other 20
the other 20 is the car loan okay how
much do you guys make a year
um we make
um
take home in 64 000. okay
um okay so
what i want you guys to do and you've
done it
is the budget okay so that budget is
going to help in the nuts and bolts of
this idea but when things come up
that you feel like
i want to spend but i can't call your
mom you're not being a burden she is
someone in your life that's going to be
able to help walk with you through that
and then i want you guys have a detailed
plan of how you're going to be paying
off the car first the 20 000 and then
the student loans i want the debt
snowball dialed in and i want an end
date to say how much when this can be
when we can be out of debt i need a
motivation for you
um but with your it's your kids it's
getting out of debt and the motivation
but erica give yourself some grace girl
breathe give yourself some grace and
it's a it's a daily grind you wake up
and you make your decisions and you do
there's a level of grown-up-ness there
that you need to have more of your calls
coming right up this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman rachel cruz joins me in studio
this hour
our scripture today comes from proverbs
4 verse 7. wisdom is
the principal thing therefore get wisdom
and in all you're getting get
understanding our quote of the day from
maya angelou the great poet do the best
that you can until you know better then
when you know better do better
speaking of doing better
uh you can do better when you look back
on the mistakes you've made learn from
them and go forward that's why rachel
and i everybody ramsey solution is so
excited about our colleague dr john
deloney's new book which is now
available for pre-order and it's almost
over this is the last chance to act the
new book is own your past change your
future
and john writes exactly about that in
this book having a conversation with you
looking back
in your past to learn to own it and then
to change the future not let it hold on
hold you back
any longer if you want to live a more
restful and peaceful life you need to
get this book it is a life changer you
can pre-order your copy today at
ramseysolutions.com for only twenty
dollars and you'll get some amazing
added bonus items for free
including the audio book the ebook and
one month of free weekly therapy
sessions from betterhelp so go now and
get it ramseysolutions.com the book is
own your past
change your future let's go to tracy who
joins us on the line in charleston south
carolina tracy how can we help
hi um i thank you for taking my phone
call
um my question my question is um
we
have some debt
um my husband owns a classic car
that we still owe we took a 401k loan
out to pay for it
all right let's go back just real quick
so we can catch up with you how much
debt do you have total
okay so we have about 11 300 in credit
card debt
um
we owe with our mortgage and then also
we took a second mortgage out we put a
pool in last year so we owe about 275
000 on our house
it's worth about 5.90
we still owe the 13
um three hundred dollars on the 401k
loan for the car
and that's at a payment of 565 a month
whoa
yes okay so is that everything
well and the thing that's upsetting with
me
my husband
watches you all all the time and
wants to talk to me about finances and i
get very frustrated because
we especially build liquid savings
nothing if something were to happen we
have absolutely no emergency fund
um
we're 51 years old he's talked you know
he talks about retiring early which i'm
on board with but
when i look at all this on paper and i
say okay i'm ready to do the baby steps
with you you know um my thing to him was
well i mean the car rarely comes out of
the garage he rarely drives it
he doesn't like to drive at long
distance he doesn't like you driving on
the freeway we paid 55 000 for it oh
what car what is it
it's a 1965 mustang fast pack oh let me
just have a moment real quick for your
husband ouch okay that's a fabulous car
um and i and i and i get that and so if
you tell me you know what you can do
this i'm fine with it i just i just sort
of feel resentful because it's like yeah
yeah
every every time we make a 600 payment
on that thing and it just sits there and
it barely gets
i get it listen listen listen i get it
um and so there's tension between you
two because you want him to sell the car
because it's worth 55 at least if not
more correct yes exactly
if we sold it we would eliminate the
401k loan that would free up 565 dollars
a month in payment we could we could i
figured out we could pay off the 11 300
credit card debt
we could put our maximum on our rocks
this year
how much do y'all make a year
um combined growth we probably bring
home about 190. holy cow yeah
listen you said he listens and watch the
show i'll do this because rachel's way
too nice i also say sell it okay good
but i'm i'm just gonna tell him hey
listen i love classic cars and you have
you i have a classic car i have a 1972
convertible volkswagen karman gear it's
absolutely gorgeous she's gorgeous
but
i don't owe anything on her
and
this car you can get another great
mustang
this is going to change your life and
it's going to change your marriage he
has to sell it you said he listens
what's his name well what's his name
it'll change the rear only the fact of
the only thing is is
like the other day and he gets
he gets a little resentful when he has
to give up his toys
yeah but you but you resent him yeah
well let me say this to tracy you guys
make an incredible income okay money so
24 000
out of 190 you guys could clean up this
mess you all need to clean up your bus i
mean this credit card debt i mean you
guys just have stuff everywhere you put
in a pool i think both of you both of
you need to sit down and say all right
what's going the car yes it's an issue
and it's frustrating because you're
seeing the math absolutely but you guys
make good money and if you both buckle
down and say hey together we're going to
do this because if if you had a plan
tracy that you guys could be completely
debt free i mean obviously except for
the the house and the in the 270. if you
all could pay off the 401k loan and the
credit card and you could do that in
four months would you be still bitter
about the car if it was paid off in four
months
i don't think so not so as much i think
i think the buyer the thing that bothers
me is i'm a person that i need to see a
little bit of money in the bank for me
to feel comfortable 100 100 well of
course this is a safety issue but that
but the the big emergency fund though tr
see comes after you guys take care of
this mess so
maybe it's either yeah sell the car
because that's going to take care of a
lot you guys are gonna be able to pay
off these two debts put money in the
bank for that emergency fund
and then actually have a stable
foundation how much is the second
mortgage
what's that how much is the second
mortgage that you took out to get the
pool
we actually the pool was 65 60 000.
the actual art so our home we owed 219
on
the the pool was 60. but so i kind of
said to him well i can't dig up the pool
i mean there's nothing i can do now
about the pool i can't dig up the pool
you know i'm not sure
um and the thing is we paint with the
housing market the way it is
we bought our house pretty pretty
reasonably about five years ago
so it doesn't make sense for us to rent
we already looked into rent is more
expensive than we only know you don't
know nobody's telling you to sell the
house listen you guys need to have a
come together meeting yeah okay
and look at each other and go we both
want to do this we're both going to make
sacrifices
you can't make it all about the mustang
right and he can't make it about
whatever whatever this is big boy big
girl conversation and we got to go what
future do we want and the fact of the
matter is yes it hurts to get rid of the
mustang but he's got to do it it makes
everything go fast forward but then what
can you do
how much of the 11 300 in credit card
was you buying something can you sell
something for two grand we both got to
put some skin in the game i think to
where we stopped doing this well you did
this or you're not going to do this i
think that's your problem i think you
both want the same future but neither
one of you are willing to kind of make a
sacrifice and both go all right we're
both going to
take on some pain here rachel i think is
the issue yeah this is painful but look
can i just say this
make it 190 000 after they clean this
mess up he can go pay cash for another
great mustang
or you guys can choose an intense plan
to get rid of the ticket to get rid of
it if you but you but you both have to
agree though that's the problem and
tracy you're feeling
you're feeling this level of fear
because you're not going to be taken
care of if something happens and a 55
000 mustang is sitting in there and it
almost feels like that's become more
important to him than her
level of safety and fear right so i mean
like you you guys have a yeah you can
keep it
it's the it's the conversation that
needs to be had of the yeah there's
marriage stuff here too so
um
yeah but but we always say two around
here i think dave says all the time
which i just love how do we get from
point a to point b the fastest the most
efficient way the baby steps are that
and part of the baby steps is you sell
everything to to fast forward this
process so
to get to point b to have money in the
bank for you to feel secure for him to
retire early all these things you all
want
the mustang makes sense to sell to get
to get there the fastest unless you guys
choose a different plan to pay it off
and all of that but you'll have to be on
this both of you
hang on the line tracy i know he listens
and watches let's give you guys a copy
of total money makeover and just follow
it as it is written thousand dollars
baby step one get that little emergency
fund and then walk it out you guys can
do this you have plenty of you have big
enough trouble you do yep you could do
this great job tracy thanks for calling
thank you for the call boy i hate to see
that mustang
hey rachel cruz thank you thank you to
the team this is the reason
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you